bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui dans science clic l'énergie
sombre l'univers dans lequel nous vivons
est en expansion
par exemple deux amas de galaxies se
situant assez loin l'un de l'autre vont
voir l'espace qui les sépare ces tirs et
les éloignant petit à petit cette
expansion de l'univers à grande échelle
force les structures cosmiques à se
séparer toujours davantage cependant
dans l'univers tous les objets satire
entre eux et ce par la gravitation
ainsi la gravité va forcer les grandes
structures de l'univers à se rapprocher
entre elle et va de la sorte agir comme
un frein qui va s'opposer à l'expansion
de l'univers empêchant par exemple les
amas de galaxies de trop s'éloigner les
uns des autres
on pourrait donc imaginer si la gravité
ne cesse d'attirer les astres entre eux
que l'expansion de l'univers serait en
train de ralentir et qu'elle finirait un
jour par s'inverser
cependant plusieurs observations
récentes indiquent qu'au contraire
l'expansion de l'univers n'est pas en
train de ralentir mais en train de
s'accélérer
cette accélération de l'expansion semble
indiquer qu'il existerait dans l'univers
une sorte d'énergie encore inconnue une
énergie invisible qui pousserait
l'univers as expandent retour de plus en
plus vite
cette énergie invisible exercerait une
action répulsive partout dans l'univers
qu'elle remplirait de façon homogène
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'énergie sont la
nature de cette énergie sombre est
encore un mystère
elle pourrait en particulier des coulées
de l'énergie du vide quantique c'est à
dire d'une énergie fondamentale présente
partout dans l'univers de façon homogène
cependant aucune de ces hypothèses n'a
pour l'instant été vérifiés et notre
compréhension de l'énergie sombre n'en
est qu'à ses débuts
il se trouve que c'est pourtant cette
énergie sombre qui serait le constituant
majoritaire dans l'univers en effet
alors qu'une part du cosmos est composé
de matière ordinaire fait d'atomes et
d'une matière encore mystérieuse qu'on
appelle matière noire et l'énergie
sombre à elles seules représenterait
plus de deux tiers du contenu global de
l'univers c'est cette prédominance de
l'énergie sombre sur le reste du contenu
de l'univers qui permettent à
l'expansion cosmique de s'accélérer
en effet si l'univers contenaient moins
d'énergie sombre alors la gravité
pourraient prendre le dessus et les
astres finirait par se rapprocher les
uns des autres
c'est donc la proportion d'énergie
sombre dans l'univers qui va déterminer
son expansion ainsi en ce qui regarde le
futur de l'univers trois destins sont
possibles tout d'abord la proportion
d'énergie sombre pour est lentement
diminuer avec le temps on diminuant
l'effet répulsif de l'énergie sombre
s'estomperait et la gravité finiraient
par prendre le dessus
l'univers se contracterait alors sur lui
même et finirait dans une énorme
collision
cependant il est bien plus probable que
la proportion l'énergie sombre dans
l'univers reste stable ou encore qu'elle
augmente à travers le temps tout d'abord
si elle restait stable alors l'expansion
de l'univers continuerait d'augmenter
petit à petit mais les galaxies et les
structures à petite échelle comme le
système solaire resteraient liés par la
gravitation est ainsi seuls des
structures à grande échelle serait
destiné à s'éloigner les unes des autres
cependant si dans le futur la proportion
d'énergie sombre augmentait alors
l'expansion de l'univers s'accélère ray
de plus en plus vite
cette accélération de l'expansion
deviendrait si importante que toutes les
structures du cosmos finirait par se
séparer les unes des autres
ainsi en attendant assez longtemps même
les atomes qui composent la planète
terre finirait par se séparer les uns
des autres et tous les objets de
l'univers finirait en quelque sorte par
se désintégrer